I think we can consider Grayskull to be
honored so a fair number of you were
probably expecting my review of the
latest Doctor Who episode to go up today
but the problem is I haven't seen it yet
I'm having a few technical difficulties
with some things at my house right now
and yeah I haven't gotten to see it so
instead I'm gonna bump up a review for
something that I have finished and was
gonna put this out later this week but
I'll do it now instead and I will get to
Doctor Who as soon as I am able to I'm
just I can't promise when that is right
now so instead I'm gonna talk about
Shira and the princesses of power the
Netflix reboots reimagining whatever you
want to consider it to be of the classic
1980s cartoon so where do we begin
well I may be a little bit of my own
relationship to this property
Shira is something that I had an
awareness of and I saw a handful of
episodes of and that's basically because
of its association with he meant wish it
was a spinoff from and had connections
to and he met I was very much into
especially as a kid primarily through
the toys I did watch the cartoon I liked
the cartoon but I was into the toys
first and foremost and so that was also
kind of like how I initially was aware
of Shira but I never really had much in
the way of shiro toys cuz yes they did
actually brand them completely
separately but like I said I did see a
little bit of the show and I had a few
memories of it and I actually went back
and found a few clips and a few things
you know to sort of refresh my memory of
what that old show was like and I'll be
bringing that up again in a little bit
but yeah in any case oh let's talk about
this new version now I'm going to freely
admit I came into this with high
expectations not because of the original
work but because of the so much of the
work on this being done by Noelle
Stevenson who
I really really really like she's mainly
known for her comics she did nimona if
you ever read that one it was a webcomic
it's now compiled into a graphic novel
it's great she is one of the co-creators
of lumberjanes I just I like her work I
like her aesthetic I like her approach I
like her ideas I'd like her stuff a lot
so I've been waiting for this one's good
this wasn't like every now and then
something comes out on Netflix I'm like
oh yeah that's right that was coming out
wasn't it this one I have been waiting
for and I was not disappointed I really
did enjoy this favorite well may I was
gonna say favorite season of animated
stuff from Netflix this year because
I've actually seen a decent number of
Netflix animated stuff this year except
I don't know if I like it more than
Castlevania season two but it is a
completely different beast then then
that is I do like it more than the
Dragon Prince which I think in terms of
its target demographic and overall vibe
it probably bears the most relation to
or at least as most easily compared to
that but so let's talk about this on the
off chance that you didn't watch the old
cartoons or don't know much about it
what's your bracelet premise well you
start out with your very clear dividing
line between the good guys and the bad
guys the bad guys are the Horde led by
Hordak who are taking over the land of
Assyria and the good guys are the
rebellion headed by some princesses I
mean like literally that that's their
type they are in fact princesses and the
story centers around a horde trooper
working away up the ranks named adora
who gets a hold of a sword that enables
her to have powers and transform into
Shira who is taller and more powerful
and the sword does awesome stuff and she
finds the sword and she encounters
things that makes her realize that the
Horde is not what she thought it was
because she had
been raised in the horde so she she it
was in case of her buying into their
philosophy like that's just how she was
raised and then she sees that what the
Horde is is not what she thought it was
and she switches sides and it goes from
there and now that's your basic setup
but there's a lot of characters and a
lot of really interesting characters
going the whole thing I like this lot
and more to the point I like pretty much
every change and update that go that has
gone on here so like I don't I don't
want to offend anyone who still has no
no static thoughts about the original
version of Shira but I'm sorry the those
old cartoons and I include he-man when I
say this they don't hold up I don't know
what the last time it is that most view
up in this stuff I actually went back
and tried to watch any of those but the
animation first of all the animation
quality is not nearly as good as you
remember because what's in your head
it's probably the stuff you saw the most
ie the transformation of adored Ashera
or Adam in the he-man if that was your
bag and the opening credits cuz that was
what you saw the most often and that was
the highest quality animation actually
in the body of the show not nearly that
good the voice work was passable some of
it was okay a lot of it was irritating
and not great the designs were okay but
honestly that probably had more to do
with the fact that the toys had pretty
cool designs rather than anything else
that's not to say the other one is
inherently bad they were certainly
decent for their time but those things
do not hold up worth him darn and I
appreciate so much of what's going on
here yet at the at the same time for as
much as has changed and refined and
tweaked they bring in a lot of stuff
from the original show but I was I was
kind of astounded how many deep cuts
from the original show show up in this
it shows that at least to me and to my
satisfaction that this wasn't a case of
oh here's a property no one's doing
anything with let's do something with it
well and we have these used to do
whatever warm cuz no one's touched it in
decades know that this there is an
honoring of it some might even feel to
the point of silliness because they do
keep a lot of the admittedly
very silly names for a lot of these
characters so I mean adora that's fine
but you know I when she was in the Horde
she had a friend who is you as cat like
name's Petra and there's a there's a
woman with scorpion claws and squirming
tail named Scorpia there was a princess
who can kind of control plants and is
really into flowers and things that
smell Ison her names perfume huh and the
one who can control water is myrrh
Mistah cuz it's like a little bit like
mermaid and the guy who uses a bow is
named bow and so it's it's kind of funny
to me that that that they kept all of
these very silly names and yet they
didn't know a way that doesn't drag it
down I kind of find it very charming and
endearing that they kept all that stuff
in place and intact while adding some
interesting twists to the lore I say
lore as if Shira originally had a
particularly deep lore it really didn't
but they're building some interesting
lore in this in a way that again doesn't
feel like it's just going oh well that
old one was crap let's do something new
it's just feeling like no let's dig into
some of this stuff and really examine it
a bit more then that old show ever did
so there is a there's also a really nice
character focus on this so you've got
your sort of core group of friends for
our heroes which is primarily adora aka
Shira it's also glimmer who is a
princess with teleportation powers and
the aforementioned
Bo who's a guy who uses a bow and that's
sort of your core group of three friends
and they are they're really great oh and
another thing that this ditch is that
the original show had that honestly that
didn't need to be there but it was there
because it was in he-man I'm not
entirely sure why it was he-man either
which is the whole secret identity thing
because in the original you know very
few people know that adora is Shira that
actually has almost no impact on
anything ever yet they still make a
thing out of it here it's like no like
everybody knows well not everybody but
like people who meet her know or find
out
fairly quickly so it's not like a big
weird secret so again the changes
there's a lot of good smart calls I
really like the character redesigns yeah
and I don't mean that in terms of
costumes I mean in terms of the literal
designs of the characters for one thing
they're a heck of a lot more distinct
from each other than they used to be I
think a really good way to emphasize
this is let's you just do a quick
comparison here is an image from the
original cartoon of Katra and Skorpio
you may notice that they have the exact
same body type and facial structure
which is a result from the fact that
when they were making the toy that these
characters are based off of because the
toys were made first by and large they
basically only had one female body type
and and the result is you have these two
characters with the exact same physical
dimensions in this case even the same
gang color scheme their voices and their
personalities weirdest thing but looking
at them it's like the same person in two
different cosplays now here is the new
shows Katra and Scorpia oh my god look
at that they're completely distinct from
each other and you can tell them by
silhouette alone
so yeah that's that sort of stuff is a
big big improvement so I'm down for all
that I love all that how I said the the
hero characters are really endearing
you've got all the princesses and the
thing is the story that is telling is
it's not the most original in the world
but the nuts and bolts of how it goes
about it are pretty clever including
some of the circuitous routes that it
that it goes along so once you realize
that sort of the the setup here is that
the rebellion is I don't want to say on
its last legs but it's not in great
shape because it's not unified because
like a long time ago there was a
princess alliance where all the
princesses teamed together to try and
defeat the Horde it didn't work and now
the Alliance is broken and so glimmer
makes the
makes the call that she thinks that
their best shot to win is to rebuild the
princess alliance and so you go oh okay
so they're gonna travel around to the
different realms we're gonna meet all
the different princesses they'll join up
and you go well that's what's gonna
happen and that is what happens but it's
also not quite that straightforward and
quite that clean because when things get
rough and they do at a few points there
are consequences sometimes prolong
consequences across multiple episodes
where there is an impact on these
characters and how they react and treat
each other based off the events that
happen in a previous episode it's
actually pretty well constructed
serialized storytelling and there is a
continuous story going on here but there
is also for the most part complete
little things within each episode so
that all works really well there's one
oh there's some other really cool
characters I like this version of shadow
Weaver quite a bit a one of a couple
voices that I that I did recognize on
here because I'm like I know that voice
I know that voice oh it's me the villain
from the only good season of orange is
the new black oh that's perfect or Myr
Mistah is heather from crazy
ex-girlfriend if you watch that so it
was fun to recognize those but it's not
it's not stacked with recognizable
celebrity voices or voice actors who are
in everything that I can just tell cuz
like at this point I've seen enough
anime stuff that I can pick out a
Maurice LaMarche voice I can pick out a
John DiMaggio voice Tara Strong some
sometimes I can pick her out but you
don't get that here and the only reason
I recognize those two voices because is
I've seen specific TV shows where those
actors I have appeared as opposed to oh
man I've heard this voice everywhere but
ultimately the the relationship that I
really want to focus on the one that is
at the heart of this and I think it was
a very smart choice to make the core of
this it's the relationship between adora
and tatra first of all it's actually
interesting that they even went there
because there's sort of funny odd thing
which is that in the old cartoon
main villain was Hordak the leader of
the horde I mean obviously he was she
was equivalent to Skeletor but here's
the funny thing most I don't think all
but most definitely of the male villain
characters from the sheer odd stories
were actually released under the Masters
of the Universe toy line which means
that strictly speaking Hordak was a
he-man toy not a Shira toy now the
reason that's interesting is that in the
show in the cartoon Katra was just a
henchman one of many and but in the toy
line because you need to remember these
toys came with little mini comics and
they sort of actually had their own
story that was not necessarily the same
as the story of the cartoons and in the
toy line catcher ax was positioned as
the primary antagonist for Shira because
her real primary antagonist from the
show was in another guy's toy line so
it's actually kind of really cool to me
to think of the fact that they took who
in the toy series was the main villain
and elevated her to what you know where
that actually kind of makes sense but
even setting that little bit of just
sort of trivia aside I really really
like this relationship between these
characters and again initial set up
makes it seem like you know exactly how
this is gonna play out because when
they're in the horde together you've got
you know cat ranted or they they are
friends but there's also kind of a
little bit of a friendly rivalry Edoras
kind of working your way up the ranks
catches lazy's a bad term but she
doesn't want to put in the effort she
just kind of wants the position without
having to work as hard for it and when
they when adora leaves and goes and
joins the rebellion you know I thought
of several like very obvious ways that
this plays out because obviously now
they're on different sides of a conflict
so you know it's gonna be a case of like
either
adora
is gonna try and convince her that you
know the hoards been lying to them and
catchers just gonna refuse to believe
her and assume she's brainwashed or
whatever else or that it was gonna be a
case of like Katra was just gonna turn
on a dime and the fact that they were
friends was something that she would
only ever use to try and hurt a door and
would be like oh you were you know I was
just jealous of you and now I'm just
gonna be a completely evil horrible
person and you know the same as any
henchman you didn't have a history with
you and it doesn't do either of those
things it kind of splits the difference
in it it is really fascinating watching
this relationship getting more
background on and in the later episodes
but seeing why Katra is angry at adora
and she there's reasons why catcher
would say she's angry the read that I
get off this is she's not mad at adora
for abandoning the hoard she's mad at
adora for abandoning her and the thing
is each they they want they both want to
be at each other's side again but they
also want the other to be the one to go
I will leave this to be with you but
they won't catch her because probably
because she's just too stubborn by
Nature and a door because she does
fundamentally believe that the hoard is
evil and she can't go back for that
reason but they each want the other one
to be the one to budge and despite the
fact that they want to be friends again
and they want to be comrades again there
that's just not gonna happen and so they
keep clashing in interesting ways and I
also love just cat rus' attitude towards
adora the like I feel like her always
around when she runs into her
haiya Dora is like this shows equivalent
of hello sweetie from River Song on
Doctor Who so like I think that
relationship is is the it's certainly
the core of this first season if nothing
else if potentially the show overall and
that's not to say the other characters
get the short shrift I think most of the
other
are yo good and fun for for what they
are
I like bone glimmer a lot they've got
great friendly chemistry Seahawk is a
lot of fun he's just ridiculous and the
other princesses are cool characters and
the villains do get some decent
characters as well I did really like
Skorpio and shadow Weaver is is also
very effective but also I feel like I
gotta mention this huh there's one
episode where catch was in a tux I
haven't had a cartoon crush in a long
time but yeah I dug the heck out of that
I suppose that's worth touching on as
well I think there are some well some
people with very in some cases very
cynical and looking for us JW stuff
already
they had this in their targets basically
as soon as Noelle Stevenson got on it
cuz Noah Stevenson is known for bridging
in some fashion lgbtq+ topics and
characters in one way or another there
is a very strongly implied homosexual
relationship in nimona there is
eventually revealed that one of the
lumberjanes characters all of whom are
girls is revealed to be transgender it's
a trans girl so those sorts of things
have come up in our work before and
there is a little bit of that here you
could you could certainly interpret
romantic leanings or in tensions between
adora and Katra possibly only from one
of them towards the other but that's all
interpretable it's not definitive but
actually I mean that's interpreted both
with some of the other characters as
well there is a more explicitly oh they
are a couple two female characters who
show up towards the end action might
even be the last episode so there is
some explicit representation as well
which as someone who was called out you
know implying stuff without ever making
it blatant you know in past videos I
appreciated that and I don't think it
was
necessary to - if that but something is
gonna be integrated to have that be the
primary characters but it was nice to
have a flat our acknowledgement oh okay
so that's a thing that happens in is
okay in this universe among these
characters cool we now know that that's
just kind of nice to know so that's all
really cool um if I was gonna make any
complaints I only have one that feels
like it's substantive at all and the
others are net picks so like nitpicking
I the the character of Swift wind which
is the horse and this is a minor spoiler
but it's like it's not a plot spoiler at
all so I didn't plus if you ever saw the
original show then you knew this or
would have expected it anyway but the
horse Swift wind does talk eventually he
doesn't talk early on and when he
started talking his personality it's not
bad I think what bugged me is it's a
little too similar to Bo and they
actually share a number of scenes
together so I was like hey you feel
redundant I kind of liked it better when
you didn't talk and then there's the kid
the character of and Trachta who
actually really liked I there's a lot I
like about her character and the way
that things move forward with her
storyline how they get there and and how
many heavy cliches I expected them to
stumble into with her that they didn't
or at least they they managed to do them
in the least overdone way to sort of
have those aspects of characters that I
really appreciated but on a more petty
level she's just got a really annoying
voice I and and there might be a story
reason for that call because like I
could get where somewhere along the line
they would be like oh you know the other
characters are act a little coldly
towards her can we have part of that be
that like she's annoying except that
there's enough about her personality
that would great on other people you
didn't need to give her an annoying
as well those are petty though the only
substantive thing that I might complain
about but I'm not even sure that I would
consider a major fault is with Hordak
now Hordak does appear but he is not in
this much our primary villains this
season are Katra and shadow Weaver and
the thing is Hordak does very little he
basically just kind of sits on a big
chair and threatens his own people you
know his own subordinates occasionally
that's kind of it
it's like to the point where I wonder if
it would have been a better idea to like
did you know drop his name and whatnot
but not show him at all until like maybe
the last one or two episodes so it's
like a reveal of oh there he is now or
in trouble but they start showing him
not like right off the bat but I don't
know maybe third fourth episode it's not
that far in and when he gets when he
gets visually introduced orally enough
in the first half of the show and then
basically does next to nothing that's
that's a little bit glaring now the
reason I don't want to harp on that too
much though is because as I did say that
the emphasis on Katra I think was a very
smart one and it paid great dividends
and also shadow Weaver for how she is
used is a fantastic villain this season
as well so I get why Hordak wouldn't be
front and center but as I said if that
was the way that they were always going
to go kind of wish they two held off the
reveal of him for a while because once
he got revealed I kind of expected him
to you know do something it doesn't
really but you know I would expect
that's probably set up for him to start
doing more in the next season but
overall I really did enjoy this
I enjoyed this a lot and it's not when
you get right down to it it's not the
most original thing in the world it is
you know those the core lesson is in
many ways oh hey you know we're stronger
as friends we're gonna win with the
power of friendship and it is that but
it's just it's just a very polished well
done version of that and I really
enjoyed it
I like the
static I like the colors I like the look
I like the music the opening theme took
a couple of goes to grow on me but it
has now and I do quite enjoy it at this
point I I really really enjoyed this
show so the new Shira have you seen it
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff you can do because there's
buttons and there's links including one
to my patreon if you're feeling generous
if not other links to check out don't
want to look at those don't worry about
it because at the end of the day you're
the council and I just run the meetings
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]